mais d'abord ce coup d'accélérateur dans
la campagne de vaccination contre le coc
vide 19 dès lundi les 60000 seniors de
plus de 75 ans d'indre-et-loire pourront
recevoir leur première injection et on
connaît donc maintenant les modalités de
cette nouvelle phase devant la
préfecture d'indre et loire on retrouve
samuel colin samuel bonsoir la préfète
vient de terminer sa conférence de
presse
dans un premier temps cinq centres
seront ouverts c'est bien ça absolument
florence cinq centres vont ouvrir donc
je vous les donne
les halles de tours la maison des
associations de joué-lès-tours le centre
de secours de neuillé-pont-pierre la
salle descartes à chinon et enfin la
salle des fêtes du théâtre à amboise
donc ses cinq centres vont ouvrir dès
lundi après-midi pour l'instant les
plages horaires ne sont pas encore
définis seule certitude ils seront tous
ouverts le samedi matin pour permettre
aux personnes qui ne peuvent pas venir
en semaine de venir le samedi matin
comment ça va se passer alors les
rendez-vous vont être pris par dr libre
ou un numéro dédié qui là encore va être
défini et communiquées probablement
vendredi
deux à trois mille doses de vaccins vont
être disponibles par semaine pour
commencer on nous a répété ça plusieurs
fois c'est un début pour l'instant c'est
un étang début il ya encore un grande
montée en puissance qui va se faire
notamment avec l'ouverture possible à
loches le lundi 25 d'un autre centre
quant au centre de quant au centre de
saint cyr sur loire pour l'instant on
n'a pas eu plus d'informations plus
d'information là dessus
seule certitude c'est que donc ça va
monter crescendo
il y a peut-être si l'arrivée des autres
vaccins parce que pour l'instant
seulement le vaccin fighter est concerné
ce que ce que je peux vous dire
également c'est que l'épidémie repart
dans le département la préfète nous a
donné quelques chiffres le taux
d'incidence a doublé il est passé en une
semaine de 90 à 100 89 dont 90 la
semaine dernière 189 cette semaine 122 à
l'échelle du département
une reprise des signes mais pour
l'instant pas d'hospitalisation en plus
dernière chose je vous rappelle que la
vaccination dans les ehpad et l'ensemble
du personnel soignant continue et à
présent aujourd'hui il ya deux mille
personnes qui ont été vaccinées dans le
département depuis deux semaines